Auf 70.000 Quadratmetern: alles Schrott.
Über 2500 Autos in der Nähe von Hamburg.
Einer der größten Schrottplätze Europas.
Für Samisi Ayama ist hier jeder Tag anders.
Man sieht die ganzen schönen Autos
zum Kaputtmachen und so alles,
das ist [meine] Traumarbeit, ja.
Ein riesiger Mikrokosmos,
der nach eigenen Regeln funktioniert.
Jo, ich hab’s gefunden.
Endlich hab’ ich mein Teil gefunden. Top!
Das ist einfach ein großer Männerspielplatz.
Hier stehen lauter Mittelklasse-Wagen:
alles Diesel. Und kaum zu glauben:
alle noch fahrtüchtig.
So wie dieser: Der Besitzer bringt
seinen VW Passat Diesel zum Verschrotten.
Wegen des großen Diesel-Abgas-Skandals
in Deutschland
ist der Wagen jetzt nur noch
1000 Euro wert.
Dank Abwrackprämie bekommt er aber
viel mehr: noch 7000 Euro.
Das ist eigentlich noch ein Fahrzeug,
was auch funktioniert,
auch frisch TÜV hat und …, aber dadurch,
dass ich mir jetzt halt ein Leasing-Auto
geholt hab’, kann der jetzt weg.
Vom Schrottplatz-Betreiber bekommt er
dazu noch Geld für die Ersatzteile.
Da gibt’s noch ’nen Hunderteuroschein, da
können Sie noch schick essen gehen einmal.
Bis maximal 10.000 Euro Rabatt
geben einige Autokonzerne,
wenn Diesel-Besitzer ihr altes Auto
verschrotten lassen
und sich ein neues, umweltfreundlicheres
Fahrzeug kaufen.
Alles eigentlich Fahrzeuge,
die noch nicht dran sind zum Verschrotten,
und auch so ’n Auto
hätte ja noch ’n bisschen gehalten.
Aber was im Moment verschrottet wird
aufgrund dieser Prämie, die dann
versprochen und auch gezahlt wird …
Das Angebot ist so verlockend,
da wird man halt schwach.
Wegen der sogenannten „Umweltprämie“
landen in der Recycling-Werkstatt
nicht nur kaputte Autos, sondern immer
mehr gut erhaltene wie dieser:
ein fahrtüchtiger VW Diesel, Baujahr 2006.
Einzelteile wie der Motor landen im Verkauf.
Immerhin: Sie werden recycelt.
Nicht alles landet auf dem Müll.
Das tut ganz schön weh,
weil so ein Fahrzeug …
Der hat 47.000 Kilometer runter,
der ist so sauber.
Natürlich, der könnte noch einige Jahre
auf der Straße fahren, also,
der ist noch komplett in Schuss.
Ressourcenschonend ist das nicht gerade.
Nach der Werkstatt übernimmt
der Kollege die Fahrzeuge.
Auch brauchbare Reifen gehen
in den Wiederverkauf.
Dann legt Samisi Ayama – wie er sagt –
das Auto trocken:
Altöl, Restbenzin, Scheiben- und
Kühlflüssigkeit, alles wird entsorgt.
Auch die Batterien werden getrennt.
Und mit dem Riesenkneifer schneidet
er die Katalysatoren ab.
Das bringt auch noch ein paar Euro.
Erst jetzt kommen die Autos auf den
Schrottplatz –
bereit für die Hobby-Schrauber.
500 von ihnen zieht es jeden Tag hierher.
Für die Ersatzteile bezahlen sie hier etwa
ein Viertel des Neupreises.
Danke, meine Beute! Super!
Über 10.000 Teile hat ein Auto.
Das passende für sein Modell zu finden,
kann Stunden dauern.
Ja, wunderbar, da ist er, das gute Stück.
Bei dem Fahrzeug hab’ ich mir den
Tempomat ausgebaut,
da ja einige Autos gleich sind.
Ja, ich schraub’ halt privat gern
an Autos sehr viel.
Und find’s einfach nur schade,
weil hier sind wirklich gute Teile
noch [da]bei.
Elf Autos besitzt der Deutsche
durchschnittlich in seinem Leben.
Dabei ist die Herstellung
ressourcenintensiv.
Das Ausschlachten verbessert die
Umweltbilanz immerhin ein wenig.
Am Ende des Tages ist auch
der fahrtüchtige
weiße VW auseinandergeschraubt –
bereit für den Schrottplatz.
Den Rest erledigen die Hobby-Schrauber.
Drei Monate – dann ist er so zerfleddert,
dass er in der Metallpresse landet
und eingeschmolzen wird.